T
UNDENIABLE, I'M A WICKED
APPRECIATIVE WITH HER TO BE FAIR
ABOUT THIS A COVER EVERY ANGLE.
NOW WHETHER YOU WANT TO HELP
THEM OR SLUNG THEM, GROWN MEN
WHO CRY AT THE DROP OF A HAT
HAVE BECOME PART OF OUR MODERN
AMERICAN STORY.
AND TONIGHT WE REMEMBER ONE IN
PARTICULAR.
>> NOW, A FREE SAVORED THE
TRAP AND SHARE THEIR STORIES FOR
YEARS TO COME.
IN THAT SPIRIT -- OF CHASING THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
>> A SHOT OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM -- >> YES JOHN BAY NO
TRYING IS AS MUCH A WASHINGTON
TRADITION IS THE CHERRY BLOSSOM
FESTIVAL.
IN THE FORMER HOUSE
SPEAKER EXTENSIVELY OF A PUBLIC
IT WAS BACK IN TOWN TO HONOR HIS
OWN PAL NANCY.
AND REMIND US OF THE DAYS WHEN
HE REALLY WAS ONLY A UNIT PARTY.
>> THEY BEEN INCREDIBLY
EFFECTIVE AS THE LEADER OF YOUR
CAUCUS.
YOU KNOW THE YOUNGER GENERATION
TODAY HAS A SAYING, GAME
RECOGNIZES GAIN.
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
KNOW THIS BECAUSE THE HOUSE IN
THE MODERN ERA, REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS, HAS WIELDED THE GAVEL
WITH SUCH AUTHORITY OR WITH SUCH
CONSISTENT RESULTS.
THEY JUST SAY, YOU'RE ONE TOUGH
COOKIE, MIKE ROSE TOLD ME,
PLEASE TELL THE SPEAKER -- HOW
MUCH WE ADMIRE HER.
AS YOU CAN IF YOU COULDN'T TELL
MY GIRLS OR DEMOCRATS.
>> WHILE THE APPLE DOES NOT
FALL FAR FROM THE CREEK.
THE WATERWAYS NEVER FAIL US,
JOINING US NOW AMERICAN MAJORITY
CEO NED RYAN, NED YOU KNOW WHAT
I THINK?
HOW DO WE EVEN SURVIVE THAT I
MADE DURING HIS TENURE HE
RECOVERED OF ERIC TENURE, AND
THEIR NUMBER OF ESTABLISHMENTS
THAT THE DISTRICT DECIDED TO GO
AWAY, BUT THE SPEECH WAS PRETTY
GOOD SUMMATION OF THE G.O.P.'S
FAILURES TO STAND UP FOR THE
WORKING PEOPLE WAS IT NOT?
'S THEY WANT ABSOLUTELY, I
MEAN -- THE EASIEST ESCALATION
FOR THAT EMBARRASSING EPISODE
WAS THAT MAYBE HE SMOKING TOO
MUCH OF THE PRODUCT IS PUSHING
AS A MARIANO LOBBYIST, LEAH
WHITELAW, THAT WAS A SUMMATION
OF DECADES OF FAILED REPUBLICAN
LEADERS CRAVING LEADERSHIP, MUCH
RATHER GROVEL AT THE FEET OF
THEIR POLITICAL ENEMIES BUT
INSTEAD OF STANDING UP AND FIGHT
FOR THE AMERICAN WORKING CLASS.
BUT HE REALLY IS REPRESENTATIVE
OF A LOT OF REPUBLICANS IN D.C.
WILL COME, WANT TO HAVE A GOOD
CAREER IN D.C., HAVE GREAT
EXPANSES, MAYBE EVEN BE A
SPEAKER, AND THEN GO BE A
LOBBYIST, MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
AND MOVE ON, DEMOCRATS ON THE
OTHER HAND THEIR RELIGIOUS
ZEALOTS POLITICAL POWERS, THEIR
RELIGION.
IT COME TO D.C. ACTUALLY DID
GAIN POLITICAL POWER AND CRUSHED
ENEMIES AND THE IMPLEMENT THEIR
FREAKISH INNOVATION FOR THIS
COUNTRY, AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
INSTEAD THEY HAVE CAREERS LIKE,
ROBUST AND OTHERS IN THAT
SITUATION LAURA KNOW BE NICE IF
HE CAN START TO GET MORE
REPUBLICANS IN D.C. WHO ACTUALLY
BELIEVES IN SOMETHING, WHO
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS WORTH
FIGHTING TO RESTORE THE REPUBLIC
AND MINISTRY FOR STATE AND STAND
UP TO DEMOCRATS AND THE YOUNG
AMERICAN LEFT AND SAY NO.
WHEN I CAN CONCEDE EVERYTHING
GEOGRAPHIC IN A FIGHT.
HAND IS PRETTY AMAZING WHAT WE
HAVE GONE THROUGH, AND CHUCK
REALLY HIGHLIGHTED HOW BAD
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP IF YOU CAN
CALL IT LEADERSHIP -- HAS BEEN
FOR DECADES AND SET THE PARTY
AND REALLY NICE IF WE SAW A LOT
MORE AMERICA FIRST LEADER
STANDING UP THAT ONLY IN
CONGRESS BUT IN OTHER OFFICES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> AND I'M SO GLAD YOU
MENTIONED THE BAIT AND MOVE TO
LOBBY ON BEHALF OF MARIJUANA,
COMPANIES, BECAUSE YOU KNOW HE
CAME OUT AGAINST MARIJUANA AND
OF COURSE WHEN HE ACTUALLY HAD
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS
VOTE.
WHEN HE WAS IN OFFICE.
AND THEN THEY DANGLED SOME MONEY
IN FRONT OF THEM, AND HE SAID --
I SEE THE BENEFITS OF -- THERE'S
A LOT OF BENEFITS MEDICAL
MARIJUANA.
AND THAT ALSO TELLS A STORY OF
D.C., REGARDLESS WAS HAPPENING
TO THE KIDS OF THE CARNAGE OUT
THERE, HE'S JUST GONNA GO FOR
THE MONEY.
>> YES, AND THAT SADLY A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS, THEY DO THEIR
TIME IN OFFICE AND THEN THEY
MOVE ON DOWN THE K STREET AND
THEN THEY GET TO THE BIG
LOBBYING CONTRACTS THAT IS
REALLY THEIR PRINCIPAL IS ABOUT
THE GREEN.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THIS COUNTRY IS
ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY THEY CAN
MAKE AFTERWARDS AND TO DO THAT,
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT, THEY HAVE
TWO IN SOME WAYS BE CONTROLLED
OPPOSITION.
IF THEY DO GET THIS STRAIGHT
LOBBYING GIG.
THEY SEE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
FALLING FOR THAT.
NOT DOING WHAT THEY WERE SENT TO
DO AND ACTUALLY REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND FIGHT
FOR THEIR PRIORITIES.
>> CUT SPENDING NED, THEY NEED
TO CUT SPENDING IN ORDER TO GET
THIS ECONOMY BACK ON TRACK.
THEY HAVE TO DO IT.
AND OF COURSE -- >> IT'S N